but let's just say 20 years from now
lucasfilm decides they want to do a
reboot what would be your hopes and
words of that fight I'm 80 years old in
20 years I will give a rat's ass few
times in my life we're seeing things
and I've been looking for this
all my life
[Music]
hi Elizabeth from gate culture in
Singapore
um Mr Ford it is such an honor to be
talking to you today thank you very much
you've played this iconic role for over
40 years now do you still remember what
it was like when you're first told that
you're going to be Indiana Jones I
remember that it all happened in one day
George Lucas called me and said I have
something I want you to read I said okay
George send it up to the house
an hour later a script arrived it took
me one hour to read the script I called
back George and I said I want to do this
he said go over and meet Stephen please
I went over to Steven's house and we sat
together for hour two hours and we
talked about it
and I was given the opportunity
of course
there was a moment before this where I
was not involved and uh and the role was
to have gone to Tom Selleck but Tom
Selleck had another uh obligation that
he had to fulfill he had a television
series that he'd signed on to do so he
was unable to to do the Indiana Jones
films
thank you Tom thank you thank you thank
you for a great career
now we know that this movie isn't like a
passing of baton of sorts there's no new
Dr Jones but let's just say 20 years
from now lucasfilm decides they want to
do a reboot or cast a new Dr Jones what
would be your hopes and words of advice
for this hypothetical actor
I'm 80 years old in 20 years I will give
a rat's ass
laughs
really nothing nothing good to say
no I mean you can you can control what
you can control
when you ain't there
everything's up for grabs
from many iconic franchise
franchise style Wars Blade Runner and
now Indiana Jones I imagine that it's
such a Bittersweet feeling but what's
one thing that you're not gonna miss
about being Dr Jones there's not one
thing that I'm not gonna miss
I'm gonna miss the camaraderie of of
Stephen and and Jim
I'm gonna miss the opportunity to play
this character that the audience has
such a warm spot in their heart for but
I'm not gonna miss
everything I love about acting
because I have no intention to retire
I just want to keep telling stories
being part of the work of other real
artists and and ambitious people what
are some stories you want to tell in the
future then I don't know I don't know
every you know I'm interested in
I'm interested in everything about
human relationships I'm interested in uh
I'm interested in the world I I would I
I have no I have no
sense of what I want to do I want to be
of service I want to help tell stories
my job is assistant Storyteller and
you've been doing a really good job
telling these stories I gotta admit as a
fan no we know that to Dilo Dynasty uh
Destiny sorry
um deals with time traveling of sorts
um if you could go back to any point of
History what would it be and why well
Jim and I were talking about this the
other day because it's been
it's a question that
has been asked before
and we both thought hey wouldn't it be
great back to go back to New York City
in the 50s when Jazz was flourishing
and had to visit that time
anyway that's just because we're Jazz
fans
but you know it's uh
I think what we do in the film is really
powerful because we know so much about
his
his past and his interests and also the
device that's been chosen the the dial
of Destiny
is not the only thing that is about time
it ages is about time the ravages of
time
how time changes you and how much time
any of us have on Earth and so it's
consistent the the McGuffin the object
is also imbued with emotion because it's
it's it's parallel is in the in the form
of Indiana Jones himself
so it's it's a it's a really beautifully
wrought
they're beautifully constructed story I
think